- [Instructor] We're
told express the point
on the number line as both
a fraction and a decimal.
So pause this video and have a go at that.
All right, now let's do this together.
So we can see that the point in question,
it's at a higher value than
four and it's less than five.
So greater than four, less than five.
And the space between four and five
is divided into one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight,
nine, 10 equal sections.
So each of these hash marks
represent an extra tenth.
So this is four, then this
is four and one tenth,
and now this is four right
over here and two tenths.
So we could write this,
if we wanted to write it
as a fraction or as a mixed number,
this would be four and two tenths.
And if we wanted to
write that as a decimal,
that would be four, and
then in the tenths place,
well we have two tenths.
And that's it, we're done.
Let's do another example.
So here, we're once again asked
to express the point on the number line
as both a fraction and a decimal,
but this one's a little bit different.
Let's see how you can, if you can identify
how it is different and
answer the question.
So pause this video, and
once again have a go at it.
All right, so here, our point,
it's not between two whole numbers.
It's actually between two tenths.
We're between three and two tenths
and three and three tenths.
So this is between three and two tenths
So each of these hash marks,
which are a tenth of a tenth.
So they would actually be a hundredth.
So one way to think about
it, you could view 3.2
or three and two tenths as
three and 20 hundredths.
And you could view three and three tenths
as three and 30 hundredths.
And so this is three and 20 hundredths.
This is three and 21 hundredths,
three and 22 hundredths.
So this point right over here
is three and 22 hundredths,
22 hundredths, and of
course, you could also
write that as a mixed number.
That is three and 22 over 100.
Now another way that you
could've approached it is
hey, I'm starting at 3.2 or
three and two tenths, and
so I'm starting here at 3.2.
And then I'm going to add to
that, not just one hundredth,
but two hundredths, so it would be three,
two tenths, and then two hundredths.
And there you have it, we've expressed it
as both a fraction and a decimal.